sommerferien urlaubszeit für eine
vierköpfige familie
sie machen urlaub in holland nahe
amsterdam es soll die schönste zeit des
jahres werden die familie wird aber nach
einem tragischen badeunfall nie wieder
die selbe sein das will uwe mehr eine
deutsche familie wird hier aus dem leben
gerissen vater mutter und eines der
kinder sterben bei einer kanutour nur
die siebenjährige tochter überlebt als
das kanu plötzlich kennt hat warum nach
wie vor unklar wir sind nun live
verbunden mit chefreporter michael
engelberg der am ort der tragödie steht
michael nun die traurige gewissheit nach
den eltern ist nun auch die fünfjährige
tochter tot wie und wo hat man sie
gefunden
ja schön montag nach berlin also ich
muss sagen das ist schon wirklich sehr
sehr tragisch ich gehe mal so ein
bisschen aus der aus dem bild dann kann
der andreas der kameramann manchmal ein
bisschen was zeigen also man sieht dass
wir mehr wie eine badewanne sehr sehr
ruhig da wo jetzt das weiße schiff fährt
ist allerdings sehr sehr große strömung
das ist ja alles sehr sehr flach in der
mitte sehr sehr tief und die strömung
ist wirklich sehr sehr sehr sehr stark
es ist wohl so gewesen dass die familie
mit dem kanu unterwegs war und man geht
davon aus dass ein boot sehr
wahrscheinlich eine welle gezogen hat
und dann sehr wahrscheinlich panik
ausgebrochen ist in dem kanu es gibt die
eiserne regel niemals eine welle frontal
schneiden sondern immer diagonal um das
gewicht zu verlagern um der welle die
kraft zu geben zu nehmen ja und das wird
jetzt weiter tatsächlich untersucht wie
das denn passieren konnte zwischen
diesen inseln hat sich die ganze
tragödie abgespielt wie du gerade schon
gesagt dass eine der töchter konnte sich
noch auf eine boje redmann sind man
sieht hier grüne gelbe und rote bojen
das mädchen ist dann ins krankenhaus
gekommen die mutter ist gestern schon
tot gefunden wurden in der nacht hatte
man noch die suchmaßnahmen hier weiter
fortgesetzt
gegen 22 uhr wurde dann der vater
gefunden und heute morgen
dann die fünfjährige schwester und es
ist tatsächlich eine absolute tragödie
wir sind hier auf einem campingplatz in
der nähe da muss man sagen dass da schon
einige leute gesagt haben sie würden
jetzt auch einen tag früher abreisen die
waren wirklich völlig fertig hier ist
die ganze nach der flug der hubschrauber
drüber geflogen und ich muss auch sagen
ich bin jetzt schon sehr sehr lange
reporter habe aber auch eine geschichte
was das kajakfahren betrifft bin selber
wassersportler ich kann das wirklich
sehr sehr gut nachempfinden was hier
passiert ist und vor zwei jahren bin ich
selber in eine situation gekommen wo ich
tatsächlich mich noch selbst befreien
konnte ich bin auch in eine welle
gefahren bin umgekippt konnte mich nicht
mehr frei bewegen und das muss ich sagen
das geht mir schon sehr sehr nahe für
das mädchen was jetzt im krankenhaus
noch liegt der muss man erklären wo papa
mama und die schwester sind das ist
wirklich an tragik nicht zu überbieten
und man kann nur hoffen dass die familie
wirklich eng zusammensteht und ja dass
man über diese hürde tatsächlich
hinwegkommt was du gerade gesagt hast
benjamin in der anmoderation
es sollte ein schöner tag werden das ist
auch das was der bürgermeister der
gemeinde konnte zu der bedingten gehört
wo wir uns hier befinden er sagt er
könne das gar nicht in worte fassen was
das für ein tragischer tag gewesen sein
soll so wie du es gesagt dass benjamin
es sollte ein schöner tag auf dem wasser
sein
hiddinghausen es wirklich eine stadt am
wasser die mit dem wassersport wirklich
sehr eng verdrahtet ist ihm würden aber
auch die worte fehlen und das ist
einfach das gefühl was hier vorherrscht
die retter haben wirklich die ganze
nacht alles gegeben die polizei war
dabei die küstenwache die rettungs
brigade alle waren im einsatz und haben
versucht nachdem es gestern um 15 uhr
die meldung gab dass es hier zu einem
tragischen unglück gekommen ist alles
dafür zu tun dass das noch lebend
menschen gefunden wurden es ist leider
nicht für alle glücklich ausgegangen
michael engelberg live uns zugeschaltet
aus den niederlanden wo eine familie
einen kanu ausflug größtenteils nicht
überlebt hat nur die siebenjährige
tochter überlebt dieses
unglück danke dir michael